yeah it's a sound sometimes I mean he
has music I find myself I'm in the back
of the room with Bobby yeah I'm gonna
back the room he's on stage and I'm like
that you just find yourself I know this
joke whether you just laugh tell you
just yeah yeah he's just myself Lisa
he's never bad is it I think Bobby could
be one of the greatest conference ever
he's so [ __ ] he's just always funny
but it might ruin him if he started
riding more you know what I mean like
that might on this thing yeah yeah might
ruin like the essence of like what I
want to know what else is in there man
he's such a you likes doing TV yeah he
doesn't he'd rather be acting but he
should just be the greatest stand-up
ever like he should just be writing Stan
of all can you even imagine fact I was
too late
like do they know I'll be you're gonna
kill him I'd be like Bobby you're
staying in this room and you will not
come out until you come up with a new
hour oh you will not be allowed out
until you that's not coming joke that
makes me laugh that's not the way it
works well it would be with me and by
the way look you can't do that and by
the way turn the air conditioning up
super high
taskmaster over here you know the US
government like I think they did that to
the guy who the Chinese guy who they
suspected was selling nuclear secrets to
the Chinese which of course he I'm sure
he was and they they kept him in the
room and I guess they would just turn
the heat way up and then they turned the
air-conditioning way up and it'd just be
these little subtle subtle thing you
know you're trying to tell me your
motivation tactic is the same as
temperature your mom joy right jokes you
[ __ ] how old is Bobby Asians you
cannot tell ya he's like 78 years old
yes knowing yeah it's me forty something
yeah five no it's all of that he's like
49 yeah no yeah he's not nephews he's
gonna be seven years old oh wow yeah
look at that God he looks young yeah
yeah well no Theo's 39 damke is almost
40 39 yeah yeah Joey's 56 likewise a 39
it surprise you yeah a little bit
yeah I can't spread he never talks about
his age much always 56 how old Rogan 52
my age oh wow how old are you it I'm all
of them I'm same age as Bobby Bert's 46
I know we're all old that's it you know
what I mean we're not all young
whippersnappers like you ask is that
much younger
how was that was Jones only 45 that guy
no boy he looks everyone at 60 I was
older than him is this stress doesn't it
well I don't know what it is maybe poor
eating habits or something but he's he
looks older I always like to go to
Twitter right I'll just age I like to go
to people's Twitter and then see who
they recommend it's always like I
sometimes you're like if you go to your
own Twitter and it says you might also
follow sometimes it's insulting they
think all dudes well the new point does
that same thing too it's like you might
be inserted in this I'm like I don't
like chicks with dicks what are you
looking at 50% of porn there's a dick in
it anyway right so they're like odds are
there's gonna be a dick in the porn at
some on I will type into my search
engine when I'm talking to Sasso we're
having a conversation about something
serious and I'll just type in this sexy
cowboy or a big [ __ ] and I just start
sending him images from the internet as
he's talking and he'll be like yeah so I
well I think for the month about what we
did away without [ __ ] but then you
search histories that yeah how about I
saw I did a food-truck Diaries Michelle
Waterson and she was stay at your B&B
and she was it's her she's there for
their husband you're sweet and this is
she was oh there's a there's a picture
of you and Brian at the house ago oh
yeah she goes yeah which one she goes uh
you know how sweet she goes but brian
has his [ __ ] in your face
oh there's probably go when I wear
I did Skippy I went which one does you
have more than one ago I'm sure which
one is it she was uh always it on the
beach he goes yo it
oh yeah Brian's like throwing his dick
at me yeah oh yeah that's a great
picture those are a lot of photoshop
like sexy you can bring that up it's a
real joy Allah took that picture with
Johanna like that picture no line you
would start when you guys were first
dating that's right
damn bro long time ago it was what I
could jump I was probably 45 but I think
it was 45 years old when I did that for
real I was 40 be proud no it's just it's
just weird that I was there it is oh so
obviously my girl took that Wow somebody
superimposed no that was me no that's
what he's really do some way them you
know sure I said to him - I feel like
I'm gonna jump really high right now
hey ah God has a perfect picture look at
that she did it with her kid she's like
click God I was like what the [ __ ]
hops right there I'm not mad when I
dance when I did ballet in theater
school
well that's very bad it was the first
time I realize I could jump super high
cuz I would jump and do all I could do
all the tours that is in seven I was
just she was like the woman is next
mates from Ethiopia she goes you jump so
high I was like yeah it's news to me I
guess I what's great about that picture
is that it's not a fighting picture cuz
you don't like what move are you about
to do yes very well you don't go in [ __ ]
first where'd I get those zoomed up to
the shorts I like them yeah where'd you
get those dude you were so much Louie
you're shaved head how [ __ ] I was doing
or are you still fighting yeah yeah man
I tried to watch UFC the other night on
ESPN yeah and I just couldn't do it you
couldn't figure it out know any law well
one it was so violent oh yeah that this
guy was getting pummeled and they kept
going to the doctor and then the guys in
the announcers like he's got a skin a
piece of flap oh you know skin flat and
I was and then the doctor let him still
find I was like hey
oh right pretty intense yeah which is so
bloody I was end up finger Rogen I said
man this is too much ya know and he said
I've seen worse and I was like I can't
even imagine it's pretty brutal so
you've never been in person have you
been
no I have a better person what's really
weird those you get you get in in newer
to that you get immune to that what's
really weird when you watch it
no no cuz whether you start looking at
something different like you're looking
at their skill you get more of a
cultivated eye to see what God's doing
so then you're like you're so excited
about the fight and you want to see how
they match how so much - that seems like
they're trying to solve each other
puzzles like if you have to solve the
fight guy in frontier has a game plan
you have a game plan and you have to
figure it out I think what you're
talking about is like when you watch
gymnastics and then you hear that
announcers saying things and you're kind
of like oh [ __ ] you're talking about
like I was like that stuff so brutal but
like my buddy Eric Koch he's a UFC
fighter he's got a fight coming out and
he's like he said I want you to you
should come be in my corner you know
like you like walking with him and be in
the corner like I'm Mick it looks
intense I don't know oh yeah your coach
use a stereo yes who's got like you know
cuz he's update he's like he's like
thinking I just turned 30 you know it's
nice if he's been fine for a while he
still trains out of Milwaukee yeah with
all the guys he actually opened up his
own training place with his brother
what's he fighting around in Paris hero
and became like this dying piece because
you stopped the shaved head look like
American History X for though long as he
has a man bond and wait 55 I have no
idea but he's got a fight coming up if
you go - he's 45 now I'm not sure who
he's fighting but he's got a fight
coming I might go - I think it's gonna
be fun it's so weird that I was standing
I was at where was it maybe Easton's gym
and I was gonna take a shower and I was
standing next to Neil Magny who fights
at 170 and I'm weigh 170 and I we were
both in our underwear and I looked at me
and then I looked at him in the mirror
he's six what was a 6-3 just yeah just I
mean he's thin but he's just still says
frame is still
much bigger it was just 70 so they're
gonna cut they sound crazy and that's
right
he said I'm 170 for about 15 minutes
yeah right not a true one said well I
feel I feel it worse when you see
somebody who's like 610 in the NBA and
they're like 225 and I'm six-three at
two more i sat next to Carlos Boozer
used to be 300 pounds below what 285 25
yeah but some people have a frame where
you go like Carlos Boozer probably was a
10 percent body fat
he was on the plane with me and I was he
was putting his bag up and I looked at
his where his ass was and where his legs
weren't like and then I looked at his
forearm and how long it was like thick
situations we are examining men's bodies
that's - 65 - 65 all your stories start
with life so I'm in my underwear with
this other guy or this other guy's ass
I'm gay man almost I'm wearin establish
I'm kinda I'm a little gay you're
appreciative of it yeah I get it
yeah I want you on though one of the
reasons was I was doing Bobby's podcast
and I didn't know he can't sold yeah he
told me he was supposed to come to my
podcast and he's like I'm doing his
podcast first he's gonna do his podcast
he's gonna come over after and then on
on [ __ ] air on his podcast he calls
me he called he face I'm not live on
there but originally he's like I just
don't feel like going yeah then he calls
you and says his who's I who died I
think he thought you'd give him [ __ ] but
Erik he's such a good dude goes damn I'm
sorry about that man yeah hey do you
need anything I'm being like that and
Bobby felt way works yeah it feels like
it Bobby lie about his uncle nine know
what vocal actually died his uncle died
25 years ago
so in his mind he's like I didn't lie
you ever have you ever done that if you
ever like used a fake dead relative -
never dad oh my sickness he's a kid a
lot for sickness get sick can't make it
tonight you know kid works yeah but then
you don't want wish some bad luck can't
find a sitter can't find a sitter or
zitadelle
parking lot but I wouldn't put a piece
of [ __ ] you know I mean how about this
but how did it feel
he still came and did it yeah people
asked me to do that podcast and I'm like
no I'm like no I don't want to well now
it becomes a thing where it's like this
like four things I don't want people to
ask me okay don't ask me to help you
move Oh
real friends don't do that go [ __ ]
yourself who are you hi I don't need
pizza I don't need like you know I mean
I don't drink beer like so though
whatever you're gonna offer yeah like I
can get myself here ask me ask me a
happy man can you help me move $55,000
yeah exactly
people go let's say I ask you guys to
help me move the next step is I go pay
for it so why don't you no need just go
[ __ ] pay for okay so I don't want to
answer you help you move don't ask me to
take you to the airport
oh okay like uber are you kidding me
[ __ ] move bro you might just run me
the airport yeah no yeah I wouldn't do
that to you and I'm right here never I
mean I've never never did I've had to go
to the airport from here and it would it
be there were two demos it would be my
god I refuse so much easier what let's
see this real trends don't ask them no
but I think another day when there was
no over like you know say ten years ago
yeah that was the thing where you'd be
like hey it's like no so I don't want
I'm not taking you to the airport okay
that's not even I'm not picking you up
either I don't want the other one is I
don't want to read your script okay
don't give me your script [ __ ] you know
me like [ __ ] you and your scripts
because that happens a lot you know no
hey can you check out just like no no
like this is because you know why
because because this is - it I don't
want to be descriptive play people
giving you books
I keep getting books like that that's
what I'm saying is it all don't give me
your book don't give me your book don't
give me your place you know I I don't
want to I don't want to yeah I don't
want to read your script and the other
one is like I don't want to go to your
play I don't want to go to your also
come to my come to the movie I wrote and
directed oh that no one is ever gonna
say okay and I'm having a screening okay
over a Johnny Johnny [ __ ] mesquita
and [ __ ] you screenings of the word hey
man I'd rather
you know with a caveat the dentist yeah
what a talk after talking to a head if
you wouldn't mind being part of the kid
yeah I don't know your script and then
the last one is you know your skin to
the point when you'd be like I don't
want to be on your podcast yeah it's
hard for me to say that because I have a
podcast and I ask people to be on my
podcast but that's a reach there's a
certain level of like a podcast you're
like Eric Griffin I know but it's like
it's weird because sometimes people get
you up and they're like hey can you you
know I see that it is a commitment it's
a contest yeah well having your own
erdogan so you're going to go on like to
go on someone's podcast like that you
don't know the person that you're also
using your energy and like you have your
own show so oh no I need it for you to
say is I've had this yeah can you do my
pocket where is it
well um so we do it at we do it at 4:00
in the van oh I know but I would rather
it's actual Bobby goes dude it's this
people been asking forever what took so
long when you do them on Mondays Bobby
Mondays at 7 p.m.
Halim you know why I started doing it at
home I started doing it at my place is
because I was going off his comedy I'm
still part of all things comedy but they
they're Studios in Burbank and there's
so many people in films this show so
many people do it there they're like I
can't get a good time so I'm asking
people to come at like 6 o'clock never
you know never happen 6 p.m. never I
asked him to come do it you know he was
ready he didn't want to drive to Burbank
so much that he was gonna set up my
podcast at my place I'll bring someone
will bring cameras we do this yeah
actually pushed me over the edge till I
do it at home yeah anything to get out
of that yeah of course I want to do it
but guys just a nice it's a nightmare
I also taught we talked for a living so
I talk I do two podcasts on Friday I do
my another right yeah just a lot then we
do this podcast on Wednesday
I got stand-up at night and I'm on the
road so it's like okay I'm sick I'm sick
of hearing myself talk I'm a little
longer on someone else's podcast it's a
lot I get it
that being said what do you guys coming
in your clock no we had a good time -
it's called riffing with Griffin Griffin
with Griffin check it out with Griffin
yeah I don't think I have the voice you
know that me and the voice of an angel
but you say silver calm I didn't know
you could sing why actually I'm actually
good thing but you get into it that's
not my way yeah I get a nigga's and I do
all the stuff myself so I still need
help I don't have a nice nerd to help me
out
I made the website myself I need a nerd
I need a you know yeah power nerd I need
a power nerd to come in somebody it's
fun you know YouTube is great you want
to learn how to use like logic or Final
Cut Pro and ever you will go on like how
do you like proper sound settings for
podcast and then a guy comes on the
screen and he's like first do this you
know that's what I did yeah that's just
what's the advantage you signing with
all things comedy I guess why would
anyone sign with them I'm not saying
it's a bad thing I'm just burn out my
work it's just a supportive community
let me say they don't take any of your
ad money they don't take anything like
that help you they help you get things
going in there and then so they have the
content on their page to help push out
the things that they're doing yeah so
it's like I don't see any disadvantage
you know I mean at this point right now
we're all like our own company with my
two of my favorite comics [ __ ] out oh
yeah they're great forget how amazing
how magical is he's always been a beast
yeah Pro easy they try to be pro pro
comedian where we like doing our own
thing I mean in this day and age of like
podcasts where we're like one degree
away from our our fans or just like
right it like somebody can find you and
now they are one away from you is it
pretty amazing time to live in yeah you
know I was talking to Fahim I was a
super team I say his last name my manhwa
that's talking he's a beast of a comic
yeah and he's so [ __ ] good that's
kind of like you're in a weird spot it's
not like comics and bringing on the
Rogues you're better than 99% of them so
it's not like they can have you open up
because you're gonna wreck the room so
I'm in a weird spot and he goes yeah and
then he was a and I don't really he
doesn't do the road because I really
don't like doing the road either he was
also this day and age with comedy he
made a good point we should have montt
he was he made a good point goes the day
and age of going into a city doing press
and selling tickets
that's really not that's not how a comic
does it these days not building a
fanbase like that even though these old
product pretend like it they still do it
like you need to KS 107 5 radio I'm like
but for you should do that Road what the
[ __ ] is he talking about he just say
we're talking about that it's not that
he doesn't wanna lose like he doesn't
want it yeah I'm missing the point be oh
he doesn't think you're gonna you're not
gonna become a major star by grassers
yeah well it used to be that you got you
built your fan base on the road and then
you got to go to town yeah yeah don't do
it I mean you can still build a great
fan of road career you know but yeah
he's saying like driver if you did a
podcast or something where you can
connect with the fans like nowadays
that's what you're competing with so
that's how you sell tickets yeah you're
right all of a sudden you know it's not
even Sunday with TV any but they almost
like they've separated there's all these
different lanes you know there's a
social media influencers who do like you
know one minute of something and then
they they're the ones that are most
successful yeah you know it's true and
then you have like the comics and stuff
like that and then now you have you know
he was a head writer of the goat-face
show on Comedy Central it was actually
funny all all arab cast you know what I
mean so though they have some funny
sketches on there he's so funny man yeah
man
do your thing and he's Afghan he's not
Arabic big difference everybody oh sorry
to see you know what's the difference
um it's just a different language and
they don't identify as Arabic Arabic
Arabs speak Arabic and Afghans speak
Pashto and they speak dari they speak
learning a new thing here from Farsi
it's like but they wouldn't be like like
what I'm saying like if you say it'd be
literally like it's like comparing
Persians to when you call a Persian an
Arab it's like calling uh it's it's it's
like calling a Chinese person Filipino
or more even more different
is a completely different culture
completely different language in a
completely different history you know in
different food and every aspect of the
word it's so funny they're there they
same religion they're there primarily
Shia Muslim and you know most other
Arabs are Sunni Muslim but I don't want
to go into the details cuz I'm too smart
for that right now
I look at Eric you sister
Brian's going through this please that
guy he's a guy at the party that always
wants to make you feel stupid that's
what crystally I guess yeah O'Brien
surprised being boring again hey look
Brian talk about science science Chris I
could give a [ __ ] about him he's never
read a book he's like oh god Brian he
read one book I think it was this book
he read a book do they turn into a movie
it was about
fire out fireman who starts fires did he
go he went to high school in North
College correct sir he didn't go to
college I was crazy because I know but
it's so hard he only lives to make
people laugh well he seems to be working
what if it was a school he's actually
very disciplined about super the things
he chooses to do he's super disciplined
yeah
working out now he's getting big well
let me know he's always working out no
never you see he did jujitsu for like
six years yeah yeah he works out when he
was on TV he worked out a lot yeah he
just amazing now he's working out like a
crazy Perez yeah now he's working on has
that kind of money and you become a
recluse come on a crazy person you know
what I mean always think he's not gonna
know how to go to the ATM anymore it's
gonna be that guy you know I mean one
time he counted naked house his house
and he's completely naked and he any his
just dick is there any goes like this he
goes I'm sorry body so nice oh no he did
go to college he's a New York University
yeah he's kind of and they dropped that
up the sensibility after he like gonna
believe Wikipedia no he did cuz I heard
him on arm sure expert with that Shepard
kinetics brought up he went to college I
was it and that's I remember oh wow
okay but we just sit here we'll read it
okay I feel like calling his there
speaker and ask him to explain his
[ __ ] college his call it asked him at
college days see about his college today
we just check it up on the Wikipedia we
want to make sure this yeah we don't
believe that you win we don't hit the
New York Tanner incident
no ask him if his dad paid for him to
get into New York to roll yeah okay ask
him if he's stressed out that they're
gonna find out his dad paid for his
degree to get in there if you pay for
his SAT scores oh hey Christ don't be
stuck you're on the podcast right now
don't be a dick don't say so don't do
that
listen I want to ask you a question I
were looking at your Wikipedia page I'm
here with Eric Griffin I'm with Brendan
Schaub yeah yeah I know you know those
guys okay do I turn into a racial thing
all right listen dude it says here that
you attended New York University now
obviously no you hold on because there
you go
we know you didn't have the grades to
get in so are you nervous that they're
gonna find out your dad paid and bribed
your way into the college youth in the
scandal I have trouble believing that so
you attended New York University in
their theater department
in shortly blood and bones I don't do it
I don't know I mean I don't know okay
all right fine I guess what are you
doing now you just are you at a coffee
shop are you driving to a coffee shop
what are you gonna do there besides be
on your phone well you know that you're
pretty irreverent I mean shouldn't you
have you we were talking you read it
you've read a book right it's ridiculous
give me five right now you have ten
seconds and some Dean Koontz okay well
congratulations who rode 94 don't google
it okay now so do you have any advice
for anybody who has a dream young people
who are trying to make it either in
Hollywood or in the world that's [ __ ]
ageist anything else listen bro yeah you
disrespected whoo
I'll take a flat hand to your face I
really will bro
I'll do it your dad should have done to
you when you're a boy all right well
listen man you're not your real dad
we'll talk to you later all right
these do to be they're talking about odd
couple the thawed couple I want to see
so funny I'm gonna Fox this fall right
now we're working on a TV show actually
yeah but you already own a TV show my TV
shows you want to ask the problem when
you're a talented as I am there's no
time in the day wish I didn't sleep how
many TV shows do you want though B yes
smartest route to go well the problem is
we know where the money is
it's in podcasting not for everybody we
gotta be number one on there for me you
got to be number one on the call sheet
but don't lie to me it's so much money
it's so much work yeah so I love schools
and I love everybody I work with and I'm
so happy to be there but well just just
when when that eventually runs its
course don't be surprised if old Bry is
solely a podcaster and stand-up comic
Yeah right
oh yeah anyone's gonna be surprised you
know like breaking news well I've been
trying to be an actor for so goddamn
ugly you've been an actor for so long
yeah you know you were on we don't [ __ ]
lot of work yeah weed was my favorite
credit yeah we look up Brian or Reba
like I feel like you haven't stopped
working um this year's one I but then I
started doing the podcast I mean but I
mean if you workaholics I was on blunt
talk Oz on
I'm Dinoco from I'm just a movie about
that Sandler movie I did a bunch I'm
Audi theater or I did yeah I just did
that I'm from LA so we're in LA you do
the acting classes and that kind of
stuff
that's how I like people don't realize -
Leah studied it's like acting he studied
singing he studied and he did all that
[ __ ] yeah well he was you know but he
was like you know he's like it's like
the the daliyah's were like the Jacksons
just not known yes your dad is up for
eight eighth he is yeah that's kind of
worked with his dad yes that's oh yes
that is a serious producer director and
I mean great guy loved his dad that
Williams is that Bayan right there I was
playing buzzer Don Reba Reba is a
beautiful [ __ ]
yeah but what'd she look like that look
up well I was a I was a young rough
rough kid that's when I just got out of
jail that's when you were Brendon shop
Reba where she lost her entire band to a
plane crash do you know that I don't so
she flew on a separate plane and her
entire [ __ ] band I think has she been
with forever were killed she flying a
separate plane she had she had a
thousand appearance oh she's go ahead no
I thought it was like I'm gonna go in
the private jet there's a lot of these
plane crashes you hear about a lot of
them are most of our private private
jets and they're not taking care of what
they taking care of this the regular
planes get [ __ ] up yeah yeah my father
worked for a Citibank they were talking
about getting planes that fly 60,000
feet in the air because 65,000 VTS this
type of it's a Learjet yeah but the
reason when I go really high is that
there's that the air is thinner - so you
save on gas and you go faster right yeah
we're gonna get these and there was a
guy who is a I guess he was an aviation
scientist there and he was also working
at the bank and he said he has 65,000
fading yes yeah I wouldn't do it and
they'll go what wait tell me cheaper now
I know it's just you lose cabin pressure
65,000 feet blood boils at room
temperature
and everybody went oh let's not do this
65,000 feet yeah what look at that from
my poor my broken heart all of those
people tour manager music fiddle guitar
vocals keyboard they all that one two
three four five six seven eight eight of
her people that's all for all news all
of her band think about that that's
[ __ ] - that is terrible thanks for
gonna Downers thanks for that how would
you bring up you and workaholics there
you go it's my fault I brought Remo did
I love college is still going on man
that's a great show you know it's it is
still going on because people are still
catching it for the first time when they
look at it on Netflix alright people
still watch you know like in my building
I live right now this is so funny these
two guys he's too like really so funny
I'm sure yeah well I mean that's
actually my first scene I ever filmed in
workaholics is that one right there in
the yellow shirt you already look funny
it's so buddy you know did you um
relationship did you enjoy I'm dying up
here did you have a recurring role on
that er no no I was a regular a regular
on that it was different you and that's
the season that I got skinny get skinny
for three kill it was because like you
see yourself on TV and you go god damn
what looks like [ __ ] is going on so I
came into that season and I was like I'm
gonna be Montez is coming in skinny but
then you know so honey hey you know so
funny as I Adam I was getting skinny I
was putting post up in an atom from you
know Adam Devine he I'll never forget
that he text me
hey man we hired a fat guy not a skinny
hipster my bad that's so my bad you
right I told him I said yo dude the
funnies not there the funnies here yeah
in the brain no I'm talking about the
face my funny is right here okay yes is
when you chunky
whatever but like I'm you know what I
mean this is my funny this is what
comedy supposed to look like see like
alright cool but also stay fat yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah you know look at you you
know a great show man you let you prefer
if I gave you one choice acting or a
stand-up man that would be hard
that's a real hard thing because aside
but if I had to decide then I'm gonna
decide stand up but I'd be really hard
it'd be god be giving up something that
oh you like acting that much yeah
because because because stand up is it's
like you can't break the fourth wall in
a sense of like it's not I want to be
four-dimensional you know what I mean
yeah like when you're with other people
and interacting like this it's different
she's like good you're improvise yes yes
and you like you you feeding on people's
energy when you're stand up the only
you're only seen partner is the crowd
and you have to like you know they have
to somehow come together as a unit and
and it's great it's great I love it like
I said I would choose that but damn like
acting is just so this is something
rewarding about it too like taking
somebody else's words and then bringing
it to life there's just something about
that that is like magical it's not
everybody put the script and should make
an impression yes yes exactly you know
what I mean that's why people love gonna
you know you see Shakespeare and you'd
like to see different people do it and
it's just like a great thing to watch
somebody that's fantastic at it and so
so so what Shakespeare was always done
better stylized and you're always there
doing it this way with their the
language was everything and you spoke in
a certain way with the iambic pentameter
and then there was a [ __ ] named
Raul Julia Puerto Rican guy big dude
handsome from New York and classically
trained and nobody's seen a Puerto Rican
bring his Puerto Rican flavor flavor and
his passion his Latin Hispanic laughs
lot too
and he was he did Taming of the Shrew
with Meryl Streep in [ __ ] the river
and goddamn and Shakespeare in the Park
and I [ __ ] right there and
Shakespeare in the Park he died of a
heart attack he's great oh yeah dude
that
it's upbeat Adam fair when you see him
right there that's what he looked like a
Shakespeare thing and that [ __ ]
did it he's great he brought [ __ ] to
that role and I remember watching it
going oh [ __ ] yeah oh [ __ ] that's
Shakespeare oh my god
he's like you know I hate the way he was
doing it was like I forget he was just
so good in there he ball rocking why he
was a phenomenal actor [ __ ] people
Julia could [ __ ] you died of a heart
attack right unexpectedly it's such a
bummer because he was such a beast he
was a not a good actor a great actor
yeah kiss the Spider Woman played a gay
man in hey I mean he just did it all he
did that's not to do back in the day
he'd never stopped acting never stopped
doing theatre never stood at what age
but see you see vibe but this is what
I'm saying like I you know you want to
be like say what kind of career do I
want to have is I want to have a career
looks like you just continued that's it
like you're like you know every
transformer movie like you know you're
that general that comes out you know you
had all these I want to be that guy like
I'm always doing yeah you know what I
mean we're like oh I know that guy and
then a caved-in him one time you'll get
that one you know who's like that what's
his name all he won for the drummer
movie uh yeah what's the white guy ball
he's he's another guy that he works all
I work non-stop
I'm against that role that that breaks
out that's what I well I work with I
work with that guy on oz and I was there
and he did a scene and he says to the
guy his wife the guy he's been
brutalizing in prison his wife killed
herself and he goes like this he goes oh
here's your mail and he goes uh and I
hear your wife he starts laughing
coughed or something and he starts to
laugh and he was the place of sadistic
Nazi and I remember being lucky after
going I don't know how to do that how
the [ __ ] do you talk about on Oz on Oz
we're gonna bear where he's all muscular
holy Oh
that looks scary playing this playing
some we looks like buff Santa Claus
right there I don't know if I don't like
that it's like salmon off you rid of
that
his doctor was like you got to get your
[ __ ] together are you not gonna make
your plan he's probably playing a
[ __ ] he's probably playing some some
kind of a steroid dealer this is what I
think Krishnan Brian's dad would look
like you know what I mean no my dad's
just a giant hilarious but you but you
you play that your grandpa you play you
play some serious roles like you know
I'm dying up here some of that [ __ ] was
yeah it was very uh it was very serious
that wasn't like it wasn't that shows
not that funny yeah what's that show
wasn't like it's not like comedy I think
that's why I think that's the problem
I think we got cancelled because we
delivered a show that they didn't want
that's show time do I want yeah but also
in the book like I loved the book on
dial-up it's amazing book on the kind of
evolution economy with my weird wig who
wrote it
ah I forgot the guy's name but he's
alive you know what I met I was on the
street by the improv okay
and his into some random lady is like
hey you know what my client wrote on
dying up here you know and he hates it
he said he hates it but you're his
favorite character Tommy
the problem with it is like it doesn't
portray like how much fun the comics had
back then it made it very dark like it
was dark it was dark times though that
yes I know her she she yes she directed
an episode there's a guy right here in
the middle William William that's him
he's the author I had a really great
time doing the show it was very
rewarding to be a serious actor you know
and it's so now it's like I want to see
you know what more I can do with that in
that world that was cool man
you know in that way yeah you know there
me you know who can [ __ ] act is
Santino oh yeah yeah yeah yeah he's
really good in that we were we were both
like just fish out of water both you
guys were like I'm really good in it I
remember solves it together you know you
know we go on auditions remember that
days we used to go on auditions I know
you probably don't even go on that many
auditions anymore ice to go on auditions
but acting auditions are always so
serious the people the people in the
room I can see even if even when you're
going out for a comedy you come in the
room and everybody's just you know it's
like what are you doing we'll especially
when it's a high-profile prom I
and you walk in there and they're like
this they're English the worst of the
English like he just be some [ __ ]
English director and then she's like all
right guys all right can we all just
calm down and you go in there and yeah
they already made up their but the thing
about I'm dying appears like when I
walked into the test you know Santino
sitting there and then we saw each other
we were like oh what's up man yeah you
know it was like then we just were
laughing and having a good time and
everybody else around it's just nervous
and like I'm pacing and like it's like
dude you're about to go in and you
supposed to be yeah relax yeah you know
I mean only commercial auditions were uh
was it hard not to get nervous for the
final one where you don't have to just
don't [ __ ] up
but Santino's a good actor I mean that
outfit that was hair like that it still
got to be cool and relaxed though yeah
that now the first season the wig
situation in the first season was
terrible they didn't put a lot of money
in the wig budget and for something like
this you have to be wearing a wig there
yeah actually like yeah yeah he grew his
hair out he was a nightmare for him
because I he had to look like that like
all the time I remember doing set to the
store and the others Jesus to that yeah
but we had so we had a really great time
we found out it was over I said um yes
it was because I felt like they could I
feel like they should have given us
another season and that that's when it
really would have taken off but there
was just so many things on the outside
what is it now the second that's the
second season and now that wig looks
better because it looks more like my
hair like mine like it could be my hair
you don't take your personal no one gets
cancelled because obviously it's
completely out of your control like if
school gets cancelled yeah but you have
if you have a shame personally but if
you have a character that you love and
then you love it's like a death like
these guys are dead dank about all your
yeah yeah yeah what happens is you get
you get you spend every day for nine
months with the same crew Cassim to you
mister true yeah [ __ ] clothes
oh you're always working together and
you work until 12:00 at night friends
yeah yeah we should the kind of guy he's
the kind of guy that's gonna be around
to grips with the yes with the Hawaiian
shirt yeah the guys you want the guys I
hang with yeah the Crips I mean but
they'll think about this cuz I had to
smoke those [ __ ] nasty-ass fake
cigarettes move the worst man I need to
watch that I never I didn't see one man
what what um the so so what did Jim
Carrey have to do with it oh yes sir
right yeah he produced it but like most
actually I wish it wasn't called I'm
dying up here because then people had
this expectation it's gonna be like the
book and the the stories were really
based off Jim Carrey zone it's his own
stories it was like you know he lived in
a closet when he first came to LA yeah
you know he had fights in the parking
lot he it was all about his own personal
stories I just wish the [ __ ]
would have been on the show like a
flying be on the show yeah if you're
involved in it being like four [ __ ]
episodes and like you know then he wants
to you know ninnies and his other show
kidding just be on our show I remember
when I was doing MADtv and it was it was
the thing to do to make fun of Jim
Carrey and and and talk about how
unfunny he was I never forgot this well
that's cuz [ __ ] comics and I was like
eh am i living in a crazy world yeah do
it he can do everything you
[ __ ] can do and better and four
and in any in any language that's
everything right be like if like if you
went to Drake's Instagram right now
Ronnie post his new single he's the most
famous musician on planet so it's easier
but you but that's what people that's
the crab mentality we were gonna hate on
Drake like you see a shitload of
comments but he um but like Jim Jerry
Wright burst on the scene he's the
[ __ ] but he got in trouble everyone
said oh yeah because he he made a
picture about our abortion it was an
abortion picture that he grew and he
just like it was like a little bit weird
taste
he missed the mark of like what he
thought it was gonna be you know I mean
he lost he went a little crazy right no
no but my thumb thing is because he's
not a normal person anymore
no when if you're that rich yeah that he
drew that picture right there and then
he just got some flax you know
had a reference to him in my stamps
stand-up special on Showtime they took
it out really thought he'd be offended
by it
Oh what they're trying to keep him mom
yeah don't get interesting right yeah
that's a legal thing right they do that
with legal no no it's just good he's on
the network and huh
they don't want like but I did it was
actually as if he's at home anybody's
talking about me love him love him and
I've seen how I loved him my dad didn't
love him because he wasn't like tough
this rug did this Jim that person right
there though when he was going through
all this I mean he went through a tough
thing man sued by his exes family she
killed herself they were blaming blaming
him yes yeah because it could either
they say you know did she killed herself
because she had herpes because of him
that's her story though you know and
it's thinking it all it all turns out to
be yeah but it's like it's all like
we're you and do sort of drugs he's like
hold up hold up yeah when when I met her
she was suffering manic-depressive
exactly that you think because we broke
up and you know she did a few drug
issues with mental what I'm saying
how do % brilliant guy yeah he's
brilliant don't don't have that beard
but he's brilliant
Letterman lately yeah do we have what do
when you're that rich and famous and you
just like you had to you had to be good
like you had to be like locked in at all
times for 30 years now it's time to be
like [ __ ] it let me spend this money and
grow a beard is so nasty
yeah looks like it's a Santa Claus thing
but shaving well that he looks like he
was in court Lincoln look like he was
like on Lincoln for school I don't know
it's a bummer when you see that yeah man
but he has a show on Netflix his Kanye
on there that says I think it drops soon
Wow
I thought Kanye was supposed to be on
Rogen and he'd never do that he is but I
yeah he did it my favorite was the way I
got it roll guitar Kanye called Rogen
they're trying to figure it out but what
is there to figure out you just go to
the [ __ ] place and you do it
well I think the economy is L kinase
worried about they just it's sensitive
why sex maybe isn't know how to talk was
he so worried about it maybe worried he
may not know how to articulate himself
just yet sometimes you're like do I want
a thorough I'm saying that look easy to
get on horn he doesn't care he wants to
do he wants to do right he wants to do
it yeah oh so what what yeah you're just
trying to figure out schedules he wants
to do it they're just what's the
schedule you know all you do it's a
little bit different but but uh but most
people don't have the words to
articulate their position well that's
why people say things like woke okay
when you say when you say you're woke is
because you don't have the words to
articulate you're losing woke is the new
we're not here this anything is not
brilliant idiots woke is the new basic
it's like when people say there won't
that's like that's just that's a basic
but you can use it for any position
correct it yeah it's like you know it's
like you say I'm pro-choice you know why
cuz I'm woke yeah I'm pro-life why you
know why cuz I'm that's such an easy way
out that's right our car because even
just did this pan on men and masculinity
and these guys these guys we're talking
about talks masculine anyhow we have to
lose our aggression and we have to be
more emotional I was like holding nobody
said there's a really good side to
aggressive masculinity if it's channeled
in the right way Steven Jobs was super
aggressive he just channeled it in the
right way when you channel it into
picking up a gun and shooting people you
disagree with you that would be that's
not good but there's a lot about being a
man being competitive being aggressive
wanting to win that if it's channel in
the right direction gives you great
sport gives you great innovation first
of all it's but it's also racing
everything may only get anywhere like
it's being demonized it's may your be
like men are men are you know it seems
nice and they speed about men and such
rudimentary terms like toxic your you
know hierarchy patriarchy it's like hey
man I'm a little bit more complicated
than that right but by the way when
people say this about like look at
aggressive things like sports like how
many times like I've been watching these
UFC fights I guess just to check it out
you know cuz I know you I like my air
coke I'm gonna podcast with him worse
fireteam we play video games but anyway
like when I watched us now there's a lot
of emotion in it lately
welcome to guys just
bhante wait wait I loved it this one I'm
saying to guys they fighting fighting
fighting like literally looks like
they're trying to kill each other right
when that [ __ ] is over they embrace and
you could see the guy like the respect
he's like you earn yeah you could see
the one they even the one that wins he
looks at the other guy like you pushed
me to the limit in lecture there's like
there's a certain thing that goes on
there like men cry around sports all the
time and it's such a masculine thing but
they hug and they but anyone who's done
anything whether it's ball players
crying but it's a football player
whether it's a fighter whether it's a
comic who's doing well on the road
whether it's an innovator whoever
creates a business correct it's so
competitive to get that level you are a
dog eat I mean you [ __ ] you can't be
that emotional and vulnerable make it
you get in life I come into the
boardroom and we're trying to we're
trying to compete and we're trying to
come up with a better way to argue your
point I go hey Brendan I'm right today
guys can you watch the way you speaks
I'm I'm feeling a little sad and
vulnerable you only follow what happens
if we came in the boardroom and you have
this brilliant idea and you go to put on
it well no I think this and you don't
argue your point like I don't like
controversy I'm just gonna back up right
within your great points or I make a
complaint to Human Resources the [ __ ]
yeah I'd be like hey bro hold on let me
finish this you fight for your idea
that's what they do they just throw the
best idea out there and you have a war
of ideas even with comics so like you
see certain comments that you love us
cuz they're fighting for the further
stage time they're fighting on the road
they're [ __ ] your fight agree was
Russian especially like I want to see
like when I watched Bill burr he's angry
and he's talking about [ __ ] we're all
laughing our ass off because he's got a
strong point of view that's trying to
dominate other points with all you its
beauty I made points of views yeah but
also go up to Bill when he was young ago
hey I know you're supposed to ten you
mind if my nephews do eight so I'm gonna
do 12 you go the [ __ ] out of my face and
right is the competition right yes I
like if there's toxic masculinity is
there toxic femininity sure look I think
what they're talking about is this I
think usually when people talk about
equality or they talk about making the
world more fair which you hear a lot
from these these particular groups I
think what they're talking about is the
idea that they don't want to be bullied
control
or oppressed by somebody who's in power
that didn't earn it or somebody has an
arrow that was just put there I
understand they're bullying me but least
give you the opportunity to say I would
say Matt a toxicity I mean masculine
toxin toxicity or toxic masculinity
which was an invented term that's very
recent I think anytime any group and I
promised you with women it's the same
thing when women get power when men get
power when one groups gets power and
there's another group that's vulnerable
they're gonna take most of the spoil did
you even or wait harder on women than
their dads in my point you hear Kathy
Griffin on Howard Stern cuz she went
through that whole Trump thing right and
she was banned from all these things and
they were asking her about it and she
she goes I'm such a feminine feminine
but this hurts me to say it she goes I
was so just because when guys get in
trouble like louis c.k or these guys get
in trouble the men for whatever reason
group around and they become a team not
that their defendant but they they
support him at the best they can she was
not not one female supporting me no one
inches it's worse for me in defense of
females though like it can't be
we don't just I don't think it's the
same that was a terrible joke it was
terrible should she lose her no no but
check it out if 60 million people like
someone and you have a severed head of
that person there's gonna be backlash
there's gonna be backlash which I think
she knows right she did she bounced back
from that or no yeah you know yeah she's
like doing her special about it she's
been touring about she does a tour and
she swung out she could've come back
that's about how she's back yeah that's
what that was their whole thing on
Howard Stern she's back yeah I don't
think that that's necessary the same I
don't know if those two things equate
you know like you know what will happen
with Louie and what and he's a bad
example so let's let's say Brian did the
same joke let's say Brian not that you
would let's say Brian did the same joke
all the guys around Brian are gonna form
a we're gonna support your costume I
might not agree with now you're gonna
back me up hundred-percent oh man they
say that men what's really really
important to men there's a book called
the way of men by Jack Donovan that this
woman was just telling me about and he
that's a weird sentence yeah
man what's really important to men
apparently is to have this these loyalty
bonds in small groups I might but like
loyalty bond like you need your group
it's really boiling to have their group
of men around them like we way
supportive yeah like I see that in the
podcast market yeah there's a there's a
group like we're loyal like if you ask
him like if I'm if I might [ __ ] with him
and we might have arguments whatever but
if I was in a group of dudes or people
and they started going bad on him not
that my instinct is immediately the
brother's keeper that's what happens now
yeah I'm never gonna I'm never going to
like especially if it was a public thing
say I was on a public forum somebody
started bashing Rogan or Brandon or yeah
you thought was your you're all my your
night you know yeah I my instinct would
be to fight right away not fight
physically but if I loved you my you
know to be like whoa [ __ ] faces you
don't know you know I go on the
offensive and that's very that's very
common for men very common when you have
a team of dudes that you it's it's or
probably hardwired for it we probably
cuz we came up for millennium as in
bands having a hunt having a fight and I
think that really is part of our genetic
makeup but see I find it like have you
have you been around you have you have
you been around female sports like
sports team not much like I used to like
coach WNBA tickets I used to brilliant
Wow and for your groupie absolutely
hilarious you'd be a good groupie for
that I got a man like feet a sports
chick like a super sports chick I mean
you want to talk about focused and like
like they they are I just think that
they had that same thing than want to
decide to go in that area what do you
mean I'm like look I used to coach both
I coached boys and I've coached girls
right now what level I like grammar
school high school you know but like
with boys you could be like your mama
should have never had you with that
defense you okay right you know what I
mean you can say that kind of [ __ ] your
mouth never
you know it means that that what girls
know this all you have to say I'm so
disappointed with how you played today
so you can do it with certain kids - no
but I'm saying buttering but all the
reaction yeah it's so different like it
like you can't I can't tell a girl like
shut up like it it's a different hey bro
when you're in a relationship with a
woman I mean one of the things about
being married or any kind of
relationship mmm I have a point of view
I want to make right how you say this
exactly if I see a tabernacle no dude
you're not then what I'm saying listen
what I'm saying and he's like what and
we argue about the point if I do that to
our own if I tone so the whole podcast
too much
that's a hue you and I were saying just
podcast it's just it's just even like
like dance doing stand-up yes
we can't you all dude I just I just got
out of a relationship that's all if this
type of [ __ ] I can't
that's how I talk you're making a point
like I yell at each other you're yelling
it so I do this no I get I'm not Brian
County like not on your podcast right
now right now so we can talk in your bag
and I'll put this on youtube I do [ __ ]
I'd like to view so I actually look like
my dad's name okay Mike Allen so she was
comparing me to some she was saying cuz
she knows how to picture you being a
little rich kid or something right oh
wow that gets my trigger because I do
this I go I don't I go like this apparel
I start recording I go okay let's get
one thing I'm a [ __ ] killer and I'll
kill people I'm like really competitive
she goes alright that and I barely out
posturing like it's done so that what
I'm saying this like that's how you
talking motivate like boys as opposed to
like how you talk to motivate girls it's
different but what I'm just trying to
say though is that I find that the
female athlete is a killer like you know
they don't
don't fool yourself into think that like
I look at the UFC there's not an army
there just like I'm taking like soccer
volleyball just like they chest they had
that thing that it's just like you know
passion they have to succeed when you
know it's like oh now having mentalities
you know men or women just wants to try
and win yeah
Lindsey Vonn I knew because of their in
it you know there's no halfway no I just
think there's no halfway if they decide
I'm gonna be in this sport I'm gonna do
this Sharks gonna bite off their arm but
that [ __ ] still gonna be out there
you know it's a accesskey female comics
iliza shlesinger
shark Oh shark when you come in shark
oh yeah yeah like [ __ ] kid that's
what I'm saying Eliza's gonna steamroll
she's gonna get her watch keys and Q's
the thing is that we event haven't you
invented villains in your life to help
you succeed like I've done that every
morning like I have to admit you know
mean every morning here's a villain list
waiting but I think that unfortunately
though for like say like for female
comics or female actresses like you know
the villain it's easy to pick a villain
as the villain is there so it's all men
you know like because you know we're not
getting a chance
it's nothing when you're holding me back
but but it but it's it's kind of work
what a great motivation don't like to
like you know I got Captain Marvel out
of it yeah we are that's a good movie
what are you talking about I'd like to
captain man seeing you feminist so
you're not with your girl anymore no
yeah we're so in love that's my boo that
is my boy did what did I see that it was
pretty extreme anytime our experiences
at any time we have a friend who's like
this is my girl and I love her here's
the ring like oh that bad huh
are you trying to convince anybody is
talking too much we love each other
every time
no I could never imagine cheating I
would so in love it's like should be on
the marketing about to be yeah yeah it's
it's a relationships are tough to when
you're in this business to when you're
like this business when you're like you
know you very masculine I guess to like
nobody teaches us how to [ __ ] talk to
each other yeah man we don't want you
know just about like men two men winning
like like I watched you with like you
were getting he was an argument with his
brother and Brennan Brennan will get in
your face excuse me sir but you're not
doing it to bully you're just you're
just I wouldn't do anyone I did you're
making your point yeah no but
subconsciously no no I disagree with you
subconsciously he for sure is bullying
so consciously it's like he's not a
bully though I know I'm not sick but I
mean subconsciously yes you're huge and
you're you know you're like I know what
I'm fine our self doing that with like
you can't do that with like my cuff was
said can I deal with certain people yeah
you're you're I'm uncomfortable right
okay then you have to think it didn't
have to be like you have to check
Brennan doesn't like when you so so we
were playing when me Brenda didn't know
iliza shlesinger we were playing
volleyball and I guess she goes you're a
prophet but even better she was not very
good and I saw his face stop and he
looked at Tony who's also an Olympian
Olympic boxer and his face is I just
spike of things I just face he goes
because we have to be a great couple
dude Eliza time he's fish no because she
knows out it she would know how to get
you out you're ready to do well in that
audition oh oh maybe because you're I
again I [ __ ] up so bad there at the
improv the other night I was bringing up
Eliza
there's no emcee so we're just tagging
off you know God brought her up and I
I'm such a [ __ ] especially in this
culture I go lazing and you know the
fans are there to see her not my dummy
dead ass yeah and I go ladies and Joan
she's the best female comic on the
planet give it up for iliza shlesinger
and she got up there with I'm like you
know I'm just trying to walk out she
goes excuse me
female oh I was like as soon as she went
that I just I was like oh god oh sorry
I felt like such a do anything you're
gonna said anything she's such a beast
but I should have said I just said she's
one of the best comedians on the planet
does she matter what she is I thought I
was giving her a big compliment it
seemed the best female on the plant
which I do think she is man yeah but you
can I'm sure you have a list of dudes
that use you would think of funnier than
her I love her you know how many of my
female friends that I know they'll hit
me but female friends hit me up about
two people okay
two people if I first of all I'm sick of
in LA if you meet a hot girl in LA yeah
and you tell you do call me her first
question is do you know Chris D'Elia
okay so that's getting on my nerves and
the other one is they love Eliza yeah
you know what I'm saying in Iowa she
said yes yes yeah bull bull bull she's
too killer no but like if you're in your
mind you were you were you know you had
a list you said okay well you know well
who's my top ten female comics you know
but that's why we have Best Actress Best
Actor that's right we have female sports
and male sport isn't that bad it's that
NBA snap LeBron to Bethany we're not
doing that yeah I mean we have we
separated on price now and if so life
you do that in life so go [ __ ] yourself
I didn't I'm saying you always say
something like you know yeah
with her there's a guy who know what to
say so like I would put Eliza personally
I would put if I had every comic you can
think of this dude I put allies in that
lineup and I don't think you'd see it I
mean she'll be I don't know we're
talking about his preference yeah I got
you talking about preference we're
talking about choice yeah to me it
should be an elitist system you know
it's like it absolutely should be you
know but it's like you know cuz it cuz
every meeting a meritocracy I mean the
best person should rise - yeah yeah yeah
you know but what ends up happening is
you know you have you have so many
groups have their okay you know is it
and then you know in the entertainment
biz it is entertainment it's also image
business - so you got to look a certain
way you got to like present yourself a
certain way so that so you can have a
hodgepodge of things so you have like
here's talent here's looks
here's personality here's and those
things have to coalesce right and
sometimes they just you might look you
might be someone that's like that person
isn't as funny is so-and-so but it's
like this other package you know look at
people it was a professional really a
great a class where everybody was
working he got like this he'd go what's
going on with you [ __ ] was talented but
you don't look good why do you not look
good this is a cosmetic industry he'd be
that blow and it was true it's the rest
he goes I'm talking about if you want to
compete you're you're walking in like
that and they're gonna find a reason not
to like you and in this [ __ ] business
everything has to be long to everything
you can't go in there looking stuff you
know things to women a lot of times and
he was talking about the reality of the
situation you can say whatever you want
it works that we know how human beings
work people are like it works okay was
run run by men yeah well guess what
the ones the women that were getting
hired were the ones that were
button-down in every aspect of their
life and so it's uh candy yeah wait a
minute what really all right dude why
did you look off well no that was the
culture back then oh yeah but they were
still talented Oh some you know actually
I don't think a lot of us got anywhere
by some dick I think a lot of them were
just you know cuz it's so competitive
like that you have those bad people like
bad people like if you have some if the
gate keeper is a piece of [ __ ]
then that's tough I didn't see a lot in
my 25 years of in terms of light you
were cute enough no no but I didn't see
a lot of like on the sets of your so
everybody still busy and there's so much
money online and you're doing your well
but we don't know what's going on behind
the scenes
yeah we don't know what somebody had to
do to get there I was you're not doing
that audition process I was a hot chick
back then you're the worst let's do some
current events Jen what do you got
you're the worst so Ellen DeGeneres came
out and said that her stepfather used to
sexually abuse her and she said that she
hid it for a long time because her mom
seemed really happy and the reason why
her stepdad would molest her is because
he would use the excuse your mother had
breast cancer she had to have her breast
removes because of lumps I need to check
your breast for lumps and she would
start to lock her doors and eventually
he would try to break into her room she
busted out of the window and eventually
ran away from home Jesus Christ
well that's terrible it's hard to hear
that it's horn and then at the same time
see how famous she became yeah you
nermeen famous you know Ron Funches said
you may be uncomfortable like you like
we did this then all of a sudden like a
female voice comes on and it's like well
I stand corrected
well to lighten it up it was on David
Letterman's new Netflix show and we have
a clip of him getting dressed by Kanye
here Oh sick I took the car you went off
this one here what yeah oh I thought you
were to say to lighten up Ellen
DeGeneres situation in general this is
in this the debut episode when's it air
I don't watch the other one it's it's
you know what they're trying to it's got
it's a long-form interview you know that
you'd want on a podcast but they film it
but it's still overly woman this is
still a podcast you know it'll just
cast me in podcast the highest yeah but
yeah but podcasts are kidding look it
like you know look at Tom and Christine
here they got this they got like a hole
it's turning it's a show you know but we
just don't need a network all we need
this like YouTube let me see this June
swag that's fire so he took him to get
clothes his labels so he specifically
went to Kanye to get dressed for his
show he just says that he likes the way
Kanye makes clothes addressed Dave oh
yeah you have yeah it's great that
they're just they're ready
he doesn't good now and if somebody
could drive me to the mall I'd buy this
yeah I like the colors I like the fit
whether they've got the jackets on shoes
yeah but that outfit yeah by the way
she's so hot
why not hurt by the way what are they
doing they look young when people hate
on Kim Kardashian that [ __ ] pisses me
off because she's not regular fine okay
she's dope okay and then they go what
she had work done
yeah it's like putting rims on the
wordly yeah okay yeah put rims on a
bitly that's not that's not that's not a
Toyota Corolla that I fixed up she had a
good start from a good base she's dope
so yeah but doctors whoever's doing that
I feel like her mom looks good too like
they look yeah here's the thing maybe
find that doc Letterman looks good in
that outfit because that outfit is poppy
$3000 good-looking older man yeah I
agree with you not smash Kim's a hot eh
she's hot so stop if she couldn't look
better look at her go people act like it
was a it was a Craigslist ad do you want
to be super famous call in and then you
just pick anybody no no but look at it
softer like you saw works out for you
feels like Kim K feel that just do it
yeah you know what it's like it's like a
buddy of mine he used to be like had
this buddy of mine named Sean and he
would be like I'm I'm just as good as
Avery every Johnson in the NBA that's
what he would say I'm as good as him and
I go why aren't you in the NBA
yeah like go go do it you mean to tell
me you don't want to make millions of
dollars like once you go try out and be
on the team yeah he said well you know I
got shut the [ __ ] up
there's girls like you do that or I'm
you know site will do it go do it go do
you know you wouldn't you don't want to
be worth a billion dollars
she is astonishing she's you know I mean
I Met Your Mother like I saw her you
know we had our dressing rooms right
next to each other and it pretty but not
yeah there I don't know what's going on
she looks ready downplay it like he's
not can I ask you a naive question there
are zero wrinkles on that face at all is
that Botox what is that all just made up
there's makeup and strike up they hide
it
yeah I don't give a [ __ ] you're asking
me how that guy know I hold is she gonna
have to put her down soon oh [ __ ] she
looks great but it's money look at all
the ones in there like Gwen Stefani
looks delicious
J Lo's v50 n yeah hard for doctors Oh 49
on side 30 Sam
Jeffrey I'm 50 I don't even know who the
new one I just I just work with Jennifer
Aniston looks gorgeous beautiful in perm
answers so does you know Robin Wright
Robin Wright looks fun I was like oh oh
but she's got dad she's got this you
know who's got yeah Helen Mirren got
that like [ __ ] man
Robin rich was Robin right she said she
was at Jamie from Forrest Gump
oh yeah
[Applause]
Jenny whoa by the way nobody prettier
when she was younger forget it and just
with full untalented yeah she was hot
though dude yeah
don't say was oh my who did you say what
girl did you say her she was Jenny oh
you both said Robyn right yeah yeah
Robyn right Oh Helen Mirren been working
fallow Helen Mirren is she's a sexy old
lady was she in now Helen Mirren when
she was younger please bring her up let
me see her right now thank you i in
Caligula no but look at but look at
let's just look at her now and then
we'll look at her look this held a
mirror oh yeah she still got it look at
that
well [ __ ] and Caligula oldest younger
mmm
how old is she though Caligula for sure
dude how do you spell call the killer
like Roman Emperor see al i gu la you
know it's old-school when Google came
and helped you out there oh yeah
her body was ridiculous in this thought
she wears like see-through [ __ ] yes I
her it's funny huh she still looks the
same it's good that's the good thing
about her that one oh yeah Kim K well
that's like I saw blac Chyna in person
when I was in New York they told she's
next door I'm like I gotta get my
peepers on her and went over there
people all of us were like toot she's
[ __ ] hot man bring up Susan Sarandon
naked liberal liberal list so she was
such a little baby when she was younger
okay I'm not mad at it no I'm not happy
about it yeah not thrilled about it I'm
gonna be on Jamie Lee Curtis with that
one James Lee Curtis is another true
lies Jamie Lee Curtis area true lies no
no you heard about you have to go back
to the Eddie Murphy places that's right
and Jamie Lee Curtis they're just
trading places check out the tips so we
get it just you know what sucks now it's
like like if you're gonna do a scene
like this in a movie
now you you have to know that okay it's
everywhere you know before there was no
internet no social media so then maybe
you got you have to go see it on-screen
no one's really taking a picture these
women were such good actresses what I'm
saying is and at the same time we're
just it was just a different time and
the hottest [ __ ] and didn't weren't just
victims to their good looks that's okay
no that is not her new movie Wow her
faces superimpose look up fighter on the
cam fighter in the kid and then put like
xxx and see what comes up oh oh nothing
Oh Pete Davidson okay fighter the kid
naked and see if anybody's made some
pictures and God you fans out there you
need to start doing that you know
there's nothing look at then you guys
aren't yeah that's a couple young bucks
all right what else you got so Chipotle
is gonna be giving away 1 million
dollars worth of food during the
playoffs any time somebody mentions the
word free in the first half of the game
the first 500 people to check chip oat
Lay's Twitter feed will text a code to
their number and then receive cated yeah
it's kind of like you think we want to
give the food away no it's like a rebate
where you have to like you know you
don't know if rebates me it's like we'll
cut this off the bar I know you know put
this you get to mail this in fill this
out up in months later now you have to
find like a pint of blood from a goat
and there you're gonna get $60 back just
give me the [ __ ] instant rebate it's
good promotion for them I guess we're
talking about you know I'm just gonna
buy my burrito how about that yeah not
everybody has Showtime special burrito
money over here to actually love the
truth and American warrior but anyway so
it's going on so Kit Harington has
checked himself into rehab over the last
couple of episodes that were released
for Game of Thrones don't want to know
this I didn't want to know this about
him I don't you know to have promised
what I'm saying I don't want to know
that cuz it's an honorable character so
now you've blurred the lines and now I
just know like you now we're fully away
and that's in the final season being so
horrible yeah it is oh I hated it it was
terrible the whole thing no the last
season was terrible think the creator's
got lazy well they were like you know
what we're all set we're good with Star
Wars no first of all they think that
they're they it's hubris you know
because they thought they created we
could do it they didn't get any good
Jade that officer wasn't involved they
don't
HBO wanted to give him ten episodes
they'd be like no we could do it in six
I think they just checked out there must
be some [ __ ] behind the scenes where
they just wanted to get away from the
New Age or two and then was just poor
guys if they're magic you know you have
all this money now that comes out of
nowhere you know not that much money
though money not that much no he's
getting like 500 episode from the last
three or four seasons he's he's worth
millions of dollars
yeah dude all you need is like a couple
million dollars in the bank and and then
you're like you know whatever lifestyle
you're you choose to live you're gonna
be crazy that's fair yeah yeah I mean
these people so we buddy start drinking
because of the hate he was getting from
the character and like the the plot it
was a combination of a few things it was
a combination of the show finally ending
and him not knowing what to do after
that that's tough because you're
attached that character is so cemented
as Jon Snow like if he shows up is the
next and Wolverine like get the [ __ ] out
of my face dude yeah no he had some past
as an actor like a moral Caillou just
like he was so pure and stuff but to the
point were stupid
you know it's like see he has a
sincerity to his face you know but she's
my innocent couldn't be on
brother like if the cast of Game of
Thrones is on Big Brother he would lose
first yeah cuz he's vulnerable on gentle
you don't tell your sisters about the
[ __ ] when you know how ruthless they are
but that's a sense of that's a star
quality they be able to be that vs first
row like I'd never it's not like what's
his name Justin long raise the Apple kid
for an hour and then you can see my
movies like him though I haven't see him
in a movie in a while
yeah go along with Justin long which is
just on expert a candid long really good
though taking along an excellent actor
dude his story on I know I keep talking
about armchair expert with that Shepard
his story on this your favorite podcast
of my favorite podcasts his story on
that is one of the best stories I've
ever heard anybody tell entertainment
why cuz he talks about how he's he's
shooting one of one of the movies he's
been a ton of movies and he's back home
they're shooting back in his home what
was his big move and he goes out Jeepers
Creepers and he goes out with like the
stuff that was his first one
we're just let's first make I asked what
was his big movie and he without even a
beat Jeepers Creepers like [ __ ]
nobody saw Jeepers Creepers [ __ ] mine
nobody start Jeepers Creepers what is
this big thing it's not jeepers dodge
ball dodge ball now before that he knows
before that wasn't ring with Ryan
Reynolds who's in die hard going back
look at long disguise but no he was also
in waiting waiting
funny people no it's not that keep going
he's just not in live free die hard
that's not the one he's really just guys
worked a lot the seventies show no it
was something theocracy wasn't Jeepers
Creepers if you've got a hundred people
and you asked him to tell you adjust
along Jeepers Creepers like four of them
will discuss Cuba scripts Galaxy Quest
he was great and that's the one I
remember okay god that was a good one
high rated movie Galaxy Quest those
great great Jeepers Creepers watch wait
wait and Jeepers Creepers - I don't know
you're a Jeepers Creepers - guy
I like to as well lead role in part one
but his story about to be in this
hometown and he goes out with two cast
mates I didn't really know and these
guys take him out there like these drunk
like meatheads take him out and asked
him smoke weed and there's actual
actually angel dust in it she's and
they're driving him and he thought that
he like they were gonna kill him because
they were basic kidnapping him and he
gets out of like launch them stuff it's
a crazy story
I was I it was such a good podcast into
a story I had somewhere to be and I
pulled over and waited to finish and
then carried on we have that's how good
it was shout out to Justin long you know
Jeepers Creepers one into imma cherry
Imam judge who directed him and they're
like he's just so good he's such a good
actor man this to you gives you whatever
you want
yeah you have to worry about Happy
Campers he was good in that one too I
don't know yesterday what else we yet so
Jeff Bezos is soon to be ex-wife says
that she's doing the same thing as Bill
and Melinda Gates where she's gonna give
away more than half of income that's oh
my god you met first of all you build an
empire a hundred billion dollar empire
more you get married and like she just
gives you money he retweeted her I don't
know if this is him being genuine or him
trying to help with the divorce
proceedings but he tweeted out that he's
proud of her what she's doing she didn't
get up she didn't get a lot of respect
for us she was a badass she he's still
the richest dude in the world like here
taking out thirty five billion dollars
okay I'm crazy now you have what's the
scene that gives sixteen seventeen but
like just to put into perspective like
the NFL itself is only worth about ten
billion dollars well look I mean a
billion so a billion seconds is thirty
three years a billion seconds a thousand
billion dollars a thousand million you
put the best it could be any number what
you have a billion dollar just one
but such a number where you're not yeah
like you everything's everything's free
but by the way by the way when you're
rich okay so you have rich crazy that we
were talking about Jim Carrey okay Jim
Carrey's rich recluse a little out there
not in touch of reality sometimes
because he's so rich and famous right
but when you have billions of dollars
that's that's just you don't know about
those people they're so rich you don't
know about them they're not gonna be on
cribs they don't wanna but they're not
posting you don't even know who they are
super rich you're sitting at the front
row of basketball games in sweat suits
yeah and you're looking like who's that
guy they don't have it so I'm assuming
the idea that guy right there he's worth
six billion dollar like bomber
see bomber the owner of the Clippers
yeah the little [ __ ] has he looks like
he works at [ __ ] Kinkos yeah you know
I mean when he's got a polo shirt on
with a khakis all the time and the guys
he's got 40 billion dollars that's
insane that's pretty crazy I just want
to like I just want to tell god I said
hey can I just take a billion of your
dollars and put it in my savings account
for a year yeah and then I'll give it
back to you let me get the interest I'll
give it right back
yeah that's that interest yeah a big
interest on a billion what's that
what's even out on regular savings of
getting two percent that's about sixty
million dollars yeah conservative so
you're all so how do you not eat there's
no way for him not to continue to make
money no like we spent two billion
dollars on the Clippers it was like
buying an Xbox you know to do that you
know that's crazy
buy a here's two billion so great with
it and what if he wrote a check I wonder
if that was like a little wire oh man
that'd be great I wouldn't want to when
you want to write a two billion dollar
check mm-hmm just zero zero zero zero Oh
God
anyway she guys gets next this year oh
Jesus exact house manager said that oh
gee Simpson told him a story wants about
him and kris kardashian
in a hot tub you know like rob
kardashian kris kardashian were married
and then Nicole and OJ were together
they're all friends this has been the
rumor
forever that Khloe's actually oh yes his
daughter yeah Wow
so they were a hot tub together all four
of them who's best friends with Anna
Nicole Simpson I'm looking at OJ right
now if I could do I see do I see Kim
Kardashian though mix them together oh
wow I mean I have no doubt that he took
care of that well what so what did he
say chin so you think he was smashing
their in half for a while and finally
Nicole went to bed and then Rob went to
bed so it's just Chris and OJ together
in the hot tub we [ __ ] up leaving your
girl with no at the time they did you
don't have murder in his eyes no not
murdering he's gonna murder that [ __ ]
okay exactly
so he stood up from the hot tub he
pulled on his shorts and he said that
kris kardashian her eyes started bugging
out of her head and then he he said he
[ __ ] her until he broke her yeah
totally break until he broke sounds like
something murderer
so around a 2:00 a.m. Chris card
actually kept knocking on the door where
he was sleeping and asking her for him
to take her to the hospital he said you
have robbed do it and since that moment
they got a divorce Robin kris kardashian
and then that uh I guess Nicole and OJ
split up after that too which you can't
believe I can't believe I said yes I
mean I'm sure they [ __ ] hundred
percent but they exaggerate so Jay the
apology talking about it look at the
beginning of it right from what oj told
me wait let me show this this is them in
the car filming there's a moment that
something happens that forever changes
that's right stand up for Janssen in
cheek Seleucia so they found out they
was filming so they made him turn it off
I always talk about for kris kardashian
yeah so this is gonna be in a
documentary that the manager who's
telling the story is making so into this
documentary of course they fight bet I'm
always okay where can I find that one
you were talking about the word word the
people versus not the movie but it's the
actual it's the actual yeah that's ESPN
espy award winning
you can see I've ever seen I'm I'm very
leery of documentaries though I am yep
yeah should be they always have an
agenda
yeah that's making a murderer yeah
Michael Jackson won my Jack's when you
look more into it that's complete bull
Sean is that right Oh complete [ __ ]
so finally Neverland is completely of
complete tarnish on Michael Jackson Wow
yeah this is new for me Oprah's even
backed off she's erased all her tweets
God took all her videos down you look
more into it and like the two guys who
did all it's such not arguing for or
against Michael Jackson I'm against
documentaries okay listen if this these
two guys if this happened to them then
you're gonna put out a documentary make
it foolproof like don't have so many
discrepancies but the interesting thing
about the Michael Jackson thing is that
it started at a time where there was no
social media so all these people these
lawyers and and and what do you call it
a journalists they now have a voice and
they've been investigating this for 25
years they've been investigating it too
but when you look at the kids who know
what I was asleep no no I'm saying that
was the so suspect when in Arian Foster
does a great job covering this when you
look into the kids who said they were
molested by OJ Simpson well I mean
Michael tax Michael Jackson and when
they interviewed the parents the parents
first reaction wasn't it called the cops
the parents the the ones where they
settled out of court
their first reaction was to call Oh
Jackson and say we want money
wow that's that that says as a parent
[ __ ] by the way but by the way no one
was paid off that's the other myth they
were paid off no no no one was paid off
they settled out of court that's see
that's another thing that's a myth like
that original guy that the original in
1993 that particular case they filed a
civil suit first in conjunction with a
criminal case yes and any lawyer would
tell you that you don't want to go a
civil case first and then how because
it's like burden of proof is 50% and
then you could take all that information
and try to use it in a criminal case so
they suggested to him settle the case so
you can have these people testify in the
criminal case yes but they took off but
also the one kid in the documentary the
main guy was now if he was molested
Michael Jackson and talked to that debt
dude not now at the time when he was in
that major trial they said you need one
key witness who do you trust the most in
this world and that was his key witness
his number-one defense witness was that
kid at the time but like I say man I'm
not in that now he comes out now before
this came out when OJ passed away he
went Michael I don't know I [ __ ] CT
so before he before Michael Jackson's CD
before but when he died okay so
Jackson's family and was I came in you
guys are doing a thing in Vegas I want
to be the the guy who helps you create
that no way oh we really have someone he
sued after that well no he's been
they've been suing for forever no not
that one not there no wait wait and wait
and suing forever and they they keep
getting the case but no no no not not
until he was denied access no no no he
was already a civil case had already
been thrown out of court before yeah I'm
trying to tell you I've been on the
rabbit hole on this you two I'm gonna
wrap it all a you some other stuff we
please do wait wait what's originally
your way impression that Michael Jackson
is definitely guilty no I'm under the
impression that that this there that
there's more the information that we've
been living under with his money
a lot of nautical even before that yes I
think the press is because the foreign
press is all over it I mean there's
people that are looking at the court
records there are court documents you
can find online you can see you look
down you can look at yeah it's amazing
stuff that you go oh I don't know if
this was true yeah but what I'm saying
is if you're gonna make a documentary to
dam a dude like the way they did don't
have these discrepancies like the kids
the one guy said Michael Jackson
molested me in this in this train
station on Neverland Ranch and we we
will he molested me every time we went
to the train station upstairs come to
find out that at the time frame that he
said that this happened the train
station wasn't built yet yes yeah so
many holds those kind of things you go
hey this is important but if you're
lying about something important then why
didn't you check that out when you'd
it's like if you're gonna like that's my
that's what I'm saying I'm not for or
against I feel like he got documentaries
or like the way you'd the way you write
he was acquitted in court but I think of
director that the director that
documentary they didn't want anybody
else's opinion they only wanted though
yeah sue and by the way no other family
does take money well they didn't take
money you're saying there they filed a
civil case in conjunction with a
criminal but that particular cases but
that particular case to the thought they
had their father on tape talking about
how he's gonna ruin my life and like you
know it was very suspect situation about
like you know and that wasn't even about
molestation either by the way but it's
like it's a weird all I'm saying is like
if you really want it it's a fun deep
dive on the Internet fun and you'll have
sympathy for Michael Jackson yeah yeah
man you're like oh he's not as much as
the monsters you thought yeah I don't
know as much as a monster is they
portray yes they painted but all I'm
saying is like again I'm very leery now
of documentaries because I go what is
their agenda but his sister Latoya was
like way before Anna's came out she goes
what is a grown man doing with 8 year
old boys and it's about time we talk
about but you know by the way but let
that but you know it's so funny you say
that you could deep dive on that she was
her her husband actually put her up to
that because they were paid at the time
that that article came that she was
saying that that they were paid for that
so I'm saying there's like and also a
lot of these allegations came out once
Michael Jack
and owned all of his music and the
Beatles musics from soda you know it's a
funny thing too the size strange I feel
I think you as I use you hear about this
I guess you think it's all but do you
think that you only hung out with boys
yeah yeah there's hundreds of pictures
of him with little girls so kids in
general there's kids in general and he
had a lot of kids there at the same time
right crowds it care helped a lot of
kids I'm not either here nor there gun
to the head did you know molested come
on dude I'm not gonna come on stop it
another head Brian no no I just don't
know I don't I don't know no I don't
know either is the thing is okay what
we're finding out is that we really
don't we dog he slept in the same bed as
boys if you see if he if he was alone
and he slept with a boy I know I got a
huge problem okay problem but you're a
being weird listen this is what I'm
saying though him being weird
him being I having a strange upbringing
and having this like you know what is do
we make the jump that he's did he's a
serial no it's equivalent to saying it's
equivalent to saying that if a woman
dresses [ __ ] yeah that she deserves to
be raped it you know that's true what
I'm saying is this like like so I would
say Quadra they smoke this fire like I
was I always think you're spending a lot
of time
I'm always suspect I'm always suspect of
there are some great look my son's been
helped he had some some as a little boy
had some issues just developmentally he
had he's been helped immeasurably by men
who are experts in the field of child
development child psychology he's they
he did they're great people and and I
know for a fact that these are good
people and everything else so I'm not
saying that but when I see a dude who's
always surrounding himself with young
kids especially boys and the sleepy
hombre sleeping over it's after this he
just said I don't what the [ __ ] you ever
hung out with a ten-year-old no I had
six out I can't I get bored I'm like I
love my son my son seven he and his
friends I'm not hanging out with those
no boy
I do think you guys go play I'm gonna be
reading the book that you're going down
you're going down a line of logic that
you're saying if you do that it means
you're I don't want to say that like I
said I don't want to say that because
there are people that work with children
who are great and they might be men
women and they're much needed and
they're also look what's the guy did a
guy have a strange upbringing yeah when
you see he was yeah he was like you know
he had a lot of issues but we're finding
out now the priests that ran orphanages
the priests the brothers that ran those
boys homes they were raping those boys
yes those [ __ ] [ __ ] not all were
pedophiles a lot of them those a lot of
those pedophiles were raping those boys
and and they were putting themselves in
those positions and I think that's you
know those kinds of things always now we
know better so if my son on on a Cub
Scout trip you have to be with him in
the tent
a parent has to be with that child yeah
because we don't [ __ ] around anymore
with that well I'm just saying man oh so
you go down the rabbit hole of these
things and like really to find out like
you think because even like again even
like with the OJ trial you know it's
like you come to find out when you would
read stuff about the civil case yeah I
just civil cases where the civil case is
where you find out that he probably did
it for sure you know I mean like the
civil cases like the civil cases where
they were like well yeah here here are
pictures of you with those shoes that
you say you didn't have yes here is the
evidence of this dis and that and that
like you know the the circumstantial
evidence is enough because people get
convicted on circumstantial evidence all
the time because we don't really know
there's no that's camera when somebody's
being killed sure it's all
circumstantial evidence you know but in
this case I'm saying so you have a
documentary about it you read it you see
this stuff but I'm saying like in the
Michael Jackson case like look when Bill
Cosby came out when the Bill Cosby [ __ ]
came out it went from zero to a sixty
like this yes okay
well that's because there was where are
the other but there are like Ted fifteen
fifty women came forward right I mean
that's what I'm trying to say yeah like
just leave a long trail I know but what
I'm saying is there's all these victims
there would be a hundred a coup
according to these documentaries
children show their own men now well
that's it we're here owning it very good
who has nothing to lose
Michael's now the Woody Allen's been
ostracized completely based on a
person's testimony of their memory when
they were seven that was given to her by
her mom and my thing is like Woody Allen
if child molesters have a lot there a
lot of people that come forward like any
of these priests any pedophile if 50
people come forward they're like he did
it to me too he did to me it's a pattern
not always though so it's just Woody
Allen's case yeah woody allen I stood I
looked that case twice to criminal he
went through - that to me I'd like Bryan
Singer it gets super well that's dark I
mean that was a civil case like people
want like if you if you go through
something horrible and you go well what
do I want to get out of this it's like I
what do I want to get in the end it's
like what you know for me that with the
Michael Jackson thing what's the justice
he's dead right you know what's the
justice do you want to do your money off
the estate right that's what they're
trying that's all you can do is name so
yeah so but even the me so where are the
bodies right where are the bodies where
the rest of the boys yeah so I don't
know so right now suspects to to be both
super suspect right with motivations
beyond it's just those two is only those
two yeah in the p-word course is against
and also one of them's the mom is like
you know a stage mom you know she would
bring him to Jack's and Michael's right
what's up dude like no yeah man my mom
forced the kid he hates that man again
just go into the the documentary part of
it is all I'm really talking about is
one of those were one of the moms
specifically in the documentary says
when I found out he was dead I was like
yes because he could no longer hurt any
other boys she didn't find out about her
son being molested a pair of allegedly
he was already dead yes so what I'm
saying is if you're gonna have those
kind of discrepancies in the documentary
better it's a good runner that's all I'm
saying if you try to freaking me do bad
if you're gonna if you're gonna like to
tear a guy down because you think this
is important to get out yeah there's a
about abuse that is supposed to be
impure matter do that or don't these
discrepancies who lose it this [ __ ]
documentary actual direct yeah let me
see you this will you take 45 minutes
out of the documentary has already been
taken out of it when they played it in
Europe they played it in Europe first so
when it came here to HBO they had to cut
45 minutes of it they played because
there was so many you know they played
it at a Sunday and walked out yeah you
should see the interviews of him and uh
guys there's just one great interview do
you see that one great interview where
this British journalist is reading a
letter from the family and they're
showing them how they're reacting and
it's just so like you just go man you
guys look guilty yeah when they did the
sit down with Oprah on a pause like what
the [ __ ] what about HBO what did he Co
do their due diligence because they
don't care Jackson family soon HBO but
HBO is like no but they're only suing
they can only sue HBO because back in
the day Michael Jackson had to agreement
with them correct that you can't put
anything out that disparages his
character because they give them access
to the neverland right yeah all that
whatever it was if the cameras access
from HBO that and that wasn't supposed
to get out the footage so whatever it is
it's like a weird thing man
but then those kids actually couldn't
sue until he was dead because they'd be
liable also so but I'm saying what
justice the justice is the guy's dead
let's say he did all that terrible stuff
he's dead what what what more justly I
guess ruin his legacy he's still the
King of Pop but you should see there
there is the one line and look at see
what they're they're suing that whatever
that document is that you should see the
things on there like they're saying that
I would have been fat I would have been
a multi-million dollar director if it
wasn't for him Larry so that's what you
know if it wasn't for him I would have
done this dis yeah yeah you have to sue
for damages
yeah they see that Wade Robson before he
sued Jackson he had to check into a
clinic because his career wasn't going
the way he thought and he had a panic
attack because he was lost
what's I mention and then he comes to
Jackson fans is all that they say notes
he then he says only molested me it's so
suspect I just like don't like it's
important you're gonna put out something
so
that like not your eyes cause we're
gonna why why is it and so many people
are gonna be moved by a lot of smart
people are gonna watch it yeah I've seen
this tale before and go hold up here man
yeah but it's like it's suck it's just
like do you do your job do you do
diligence actually that pose hey that
[ __ ] was entertaining though that's just
super entertaining I gotta leave in like
five minutes - yeah one chin let's do
two quick ones here real quick how about
no more no less
LeBron James this is from Barstow Sports
they say you throw it through like the
worst house party and if you look at it
it's just him and his boys in his
backyard damn it they pulled it down no
this is just sometimes it loads that way
oh but this is through his story okay
nevermind it's probably done they pulled
it down but it was just him with his
boys like four or five his boys loud
music a bunch of chairs and then they're
like a what did we call those a
billboard whatever yelling stuff and
they were just smoking and drinking
yes smoking cigars LeBron James is 35
okay yeah not what she could for you
that video though I just think it's
going to be like he's 35 they want to be
like a Logan pool party he's got an 18
year old kid about to go to school he's
he's he's up you're the NBA and he's a
dad oh yeah all right no he's a dad sons
it's a piece of the only party that
would have been worse I got his son on
my part please it's like a book club
the voting rights well campaign finance
reform yeah that's a broad yeah he's not
young he's not a young man trying to
find the video later though it's got his
uh let's see a lettuce Aria beast he
just put his son on Instagram he'd let
him do it and he got a million followers
like this this one's about the
documentary type thing tell you you
watch it play it play this is kooky I
mean if I play it's gonna be weird so
anyways the juror or not the Joker that
movie The Dark Knight came out at a
certain date no you're not tell the
story [ __ ] do it please Kobe Bryant's
agent who's now the GM for the Lakers
it's a drop a link he's telling a story
to like the Laker guys he's trying to
like because he used to be Kobe's agent
trying to motivate him he's trying to
motivate them and he's saying what Kobe
used his motivation play really quick
story there was one time when Kobe who I
worked with for eighteen years was going
back to play Madison Square Garden and
he had just seen the Dark Knight
obviously you guys saw that movie and
he's like hey hooked me up with dinner
with Heath Ledger because he got so
locked into that role I want to know how
he mentally went there and so he had
dinner with Heath eat okay that's enough
pause ha Heath Ledger hit him was
already dead that never happened okay
he's let her die before this money came
out so did kobe say that though or dude
come on oh no co he's like why is coming
out with like keep my name out your
mouth yeah they don't like I've said I
like the MU Kobe was known to little to
just find winners and want to talk
here's a point here's a problem in
society right now I guess a problem what
this guy is trying to do he's trying to
motivate these young look out lazy then
they're not even they're unmotivated in
the crowd right now look at her they
don't give a [ __ ] the wrong start is
talking and they're like this their rich
entitled [ __ ] yes right and he's
trying to come up with a story to
motivate them the problem in society
right now is that's being taped and
broadcast on the ED and it could be fat
check also also those kids some are on
their phones ago Heath Ledger Kobe yeah
well no man II died though
said that like that oh that's just so
you know it's just a weird so he's up do
better you do better isn't it kind of
we're not Robin Thicke it looks like a
sort of skinny Bryan Callen you know
well especially next to the rock yeah
that's like you this is you and Brendan
all natural Brendan yeah does it matter
like he's not doing like no he's not
gonna test him for sterilizing meeting
he's so awesome yeah but look at him
gotta love you you get the rock to save
things what's funny is the lemon he's
labeled my podcast with my co-host he's
Lakers I think it'll save my part so you
care not really like he's like dude
rocks down the story trying to motivate
them and then they pan it's just the you
know these yeah young millionaire
basketball players like all right dude
yeah we can't relate to them cuz they're
like hey we did something to your not
how hard it is to sit in this room yes
with the LA Lakers yeah well like your
information may not be helping me I just
wanna win games
Kobe should be talking to me have-have
[ __ ] why with a bronze should be and
HEVC Kobe's got a show called details
yeah way breaks down like he is the most
boring [ __ ] like it is so thin
assassin boring that's so funny like you
would love it is a similar cadence I
don't know man very super entertaining
dude on you I'm just a Superman I got a
roll man all right now details are Bryan
Callen my new podcast
yeah rhythm with Griffin and Brian towns
gonna be on in a cut in a few weeks that
episode we already did dynamic fun honey
I'm gonna be at Nyack New York LA levity
live I heard good snack right was last
Nyack weekend I don't know when this is
coming out tonight yes oh I'll be so
this weekend guys tomorrow or whatever
the today whatever day it is out there
so come on check me out Indianapolis
I'll be there June 6 7 8 still some
tickets left
yeah Las Vegas me and Brennan shop the
show Orlean showroom the June 15th
there'll be a book reading at the end of
the show I'll be making a reading list
for all Eric Griffin will be reading
from the book Tempe Arizona that'd be
great
Tempe Arizona my new tour book worm
comes out 21 and 22 come to the Tempe
improv you pass hi guys I'm in Cleveland
this Thursday Friday Saturday hilarities
Cleveland great club I'm excited me out
of a dog pound come get it
Burbank next I think that's Friday
that's June 8th
I got Rappaport when just like meme just
in Burbank flappers what can you know
they'll figure it out you know just I
want all of Burbank together flappers I
got Michael rapport and Fahim with me on
that show that's one show only Vegas
with Kalyn hundred tickets left and then
Calgary just Mount Yuk Yuk's Calgary and
then Brea after that get your tickets
teapot gay.com aircrew preciate you
brother thank you guys this is the fine
kid we're out yeah